all right everybody welcome back to
another YouTube hang out super excited
to be here again with you for the third
or fourth hang out of the day it's a
crazy day I've got my special guest
filipe back with me again he was on last
week you guys could see him because we
were having some tech difficulties but
he's back he's got his webcam on and
we're talking about his business and
also lessons learned for you guys as
entrepreneurs and shift into type of
gratitude as well so Philippe welcome
back then thank you very much even I'm
happy you can see your by your finish
right right now I just dropped a bottle
of water here but everything's fine
buddy that's from Brazil be able do to
see the face now man last time we were
talking I saw this picture of you is a
great picture smiling picture but it's
great to see the men in action himself
there so welcome apartment thanks man
thank you even my pleasure to be here
with you get so for the people watching
to give them a little bit of background
can you tell us about your company what
you do so we can kind of get into a
discussion afterwards what is your
business all about sure thing guys I'm
finna PGM from Brazil I'm uh I was a
frustrated English student and then I
convinced mom and then just sent me to a
public school in New Zealand after
graduating my my high school there I
started working as everything I could
and then one day mom called me and said
filippi we love we miss you so much
please come back home it's time to leave
addict said okay no worries mom I'll be
I'll be going soon and then I came back
and went to the to the Skua had flunked
and I asked them to be their teacher
they told me you're crazy but then I
took it
test and I could I became a teacher
there too and then started doing a post
graduation course and Internet
graduation in international relations
both read in a teaching and learning
English then I studied business in
Oxford went to Georgetown for a
Leadership Program that's everything's
leaking here let me just try to dry it
out a little bit okay so uh then my i
started i became a professor at the at
two universities here teaching both
english and international relations
globalization international politics
then I I had a very bad car accident
that just made me think of of my life of
my future of what i was doing my dream
was always to be a millionaire until the
day i saw money's very limited money
doesn't cover the most important factors
of our lives so to talk about the
business now that you-you founded what
it's all about to give people a little
more context yeah and then uh it was
2011 i had this car accident and decided
to thank god for being alive to thank
God for for the miracle ahead have been
given and I started uploading classes
video classes of anguish on youtube
since the very basic levels our class
number one is hello hi good morning good
afternoon ed and then since then I
decided to dedicate my life to to this
English horse and since then we have
taught 20 million glasses for 181 for
thousands of students in 181 countries
worldwide I love it now people are
asking in the live chat about the map
you have behind you and I am what the
thoughts signify their so what's the
story with the map let me show you guys
here we've got and we'll see an
enchilada which is our Portuguese to
English platform here is where I am NOT
the grocery loosu so they could have an
idea than that yeah this like that you
are here like that yeah so here this is
Brazil decentralized impreza middle of
the country you guys are up here right
even yep yeah so that is ah the t-shirt
from the olympic games here in brazil it
was a torchbearer 444 Brazilian some
parts and we have two left three
platforms right now we have portuguese
to english spanish to english in we're
just starting chinese to english so
there are two dots here one dog is for
Persephone chewata the white dot and the
blue dot or grey dot for to open in the
cellar just Spanish to aim and all these
dots are the places where we have
students so it's all over the world yeah
these are the countries where we have
yeah and here are some Sun certificates
uh some stuff there are some stuff from
YouTube and yeah so let's talk about
giving some advice for entrepreneurs
you've got a bunch of people here who
want to set their own businesses have
started throwing business trying to get
to the next level what kind of feedback
would you give them on turning their
thing into a full-time business or
getting their business
to the next level some lessons that
you've learned in building your company
mmm even we I think we have pretty much
the same opinion about about how to grow
a business and one of the key factors is
providing value to to your to your
customers to your clients to your fans
to to the people who follow you I always
I always share three things when people
ask me to talk ask me to to give a
lecture I always take three three things
that work with me I I avoid saying three
advice I avoid saying advice or lessons
because each person does whatever he or
she wants and free first but three
things that worked very well with me is
what you like to do do what you love to
do and do it well be excellent in
whatever you do this is number one in my
opinion seventh is there is no perfect
moment there is no right moment to start
something right now you even you have a
problem at your family I do I have it
too and everyone who is watching us is
having a problem right now with their in
their families if we have if we stop
what we want to do or if we wait for the
problems to be over you never be ready
because there will always be challenges
in our personal lives in our career so
there is no perfect moment so if you
want to start something do it now start
now oh but I don't have the conditions
no worries do it dude dude and third is
work work work work very hard the three
things I always say are these ones do
what you like and be excellent
second there is no perfect moment and
third work work work 11 some great great
feedback and echoes a lot of stuff that
I've been saying as well too so we're on
the same page there shut it to Rafael
out who's from Brazil watching us live
to from Rio so you got got some
Brazilian fans here too all right when
we're talking about this session you
wanted to call it gratitude will change
your life so the focus on gratitude
something I believe in we do a daily
gratitude stream on my youtube channel
every morning at nine a.m. eastern for
10 minutes I share three things I'm
grateful for the people in the live chat
share through things are great before
and something we do every day I talk to
me about the role of gratitude in
business how it's affected you obviously
it's very important you because we named
it gratitude will change your life so
what's the role of gratitude and
business as an entrepreneur for you
there is no business without gratitude
my opinion there is no business at all
without gratitude and we need to to
learn and to be aware of the importance
of gratitude sometimes people do
something for us and I won't i'll give
it back because you know this is
important this is important i my my life
my number one gratitude is to God I
thank God every single day for being
alive by the way let me let me show you
guys another part of our off that glass
thing can you see that thing God yeah
yeah okay okay yeah so I have that
written full time on on that glass cuz
and never be and having a big space of
that to be remembered to be grateful
every day how does that affect business
it makes you grow it makes you happy
makes you a better person remembering to
think by actions not only with words who
make you much more successful person I
have seen it I have seen it in my life
before the accident I had my focus was
being a millionaire after my accident my
focus was giving back thanking God for
being alive after a miracle I received
and then i can tell you today on much me
I'm much happier than I was I have a
huge impact I didn't have any but before
this accident you see I think it's
without gratitude there is no business I
wonder how do you sign a couple things
that come to mind I wonder what is your
so you have it on the wall right like
you know where you're facing that every
day you've got this thank God you know
the wall this other words around it what
are some of the things that you do to
keep the gratitude in mind cuz you know
entrepreneur a lot of stuff happening
you're managing a team you've got all
these customers and all these countries
you know crazy hours working how do you
remember what what is your schedule look
like do you have rituals how do you
remember to stay grateful even I believe
the the best way to to remember is to
set rules on what you do when we started
without a job Otto when we started our
course they're the basic rule was all
our classes are and will be free forever
with a rule to follow you know you don't
forget gratitude you don't forget
granted it's very easy to forget
gratitude if you don't set rules to
yourself if you don't set rules
your business our value our value number
one here at four separate your warrant
to open in the zone and you speak now
our platforms in our offices our value
number one is gratitude then we have
dedication honesty being fast and
efficient in whatever you do and
meritocracy meritocracy why meritocracy
because it connects to gratitude it
connects your edited the more you put in
the more you get out so what are some of
the rituals that you will do you
schedule it in do you like first thing
you get into the office you look at the
wall and your reflector before you're
going to bed or what are some of the
things that you schedule in that you do
every day to stay grateful hi I'm always
I'm always thinking about for being
alive when I start my day I pray when I
finish my day I pray I'm always thanking
my knee my team to be with me to dream
big with me I'm always thanking my
students to follow our classes to give
us feedback to help us improve to spread
the word about us we never invested any
sent in marketing even never invested
any sense in marketing and we've thought
20 million classes students we have
students in 181 countries so that's I
remember I remember to be grateful every
single day every single day and I
believe it said obligation it's an
obligation to be grateful it's an
obligation to be it's not nice or it's
important it's an obligation to be
grateful and to give back so one of the
live viewers sue med hope I pronounced
that okay is asking can you please tell
us how to express our gratitude the way
you prefer the way you prefer you can
you can express
you're ready to with words saying things
to people basically if you love your mom
if you admire her come to her and say
mom I love you I'm grateful for
everything with words you can take you
can show your gratitude with gesture
with actions you can show your gratitude
some people like to listen to to your
granted so say thank done somehow other
people prefer gesture prefer you to take
action take action I believe action is
more important than words but the way
you prefer the way you prefer think of a
way to show your gratitude go ahead and
do it but I would also say it may not
always involve another person yeah no
gratitude for his mom or something else
that he can actually demonstrate but
maybe he's grateful for the Sun today
right if nobody but you still feeling it
where it's just taking two minutes to
sit there and think about the thing is
that you have in fact you guys are
watching industry x percent of the
people in the world right like you care
about self-development you have an
internet connection right you have time
to sit and learn and improve yourself
you're ahead of most of the world and
you think you have all these problems
but right now you're you're pretty lucky
you know this is a lot of people who've
done a lot more already with less than
what you already have now and yes you
want to be ambitious and you want to
grow and you want to make it impact you
want to build your business but on the
same side you can still be grateful for
what you do have and that makes you
happier healthier you know more
successful entrepreneur least in my mind
so you know you already bring it up
philly but you do it through prayer
doesn't always have to be an action for
somebody else if you're grateful for
something else around you two right sure
sure thing and
are the simple things too even as you
said thanks for this lovely sky today
thanks for this a sunrise thanks for
this sunset and something I i do a lot
is I talk to myself I talk to myself
while I listen to my voice being
grateful for the things being grateful
for things i have em for things i wanna
have I think things I want to help I
thank God for things I want to help and
the word God in your world can be Christ
can be spirit can be energy can the
nature can be the world can be mother
can be whoever whoever can be any any
power if any energy you are grateful for
there's a follow-up question which I
think you can answer but it's good to
bring it up I'm asking about the
difference between writing down your
your gratitude in a notebook versus
saying it I do both and I recommend you
guys to do both to you saw that you saw
that glass that last they're up there we
have annual goes and then we have thank
God and under that blow thank God we
have the month monthly goals and in this
small notebook here I have my notes my
to-do lists so i will write them down i
write them down all the time and i also
say i also say there is a valve here in
our office every time each one of us
there some people here when someone
reaches the goal this person goes to the
bell and this person rings
belen we have Leo here that when someone
goes to the bell everyone stays around
this person with applause until the
moment this person stops ringing the
bell so we celebrate our our our ghost
our achievements we celebrate them and I
personally write a lot of them every
everywhere and I love being very
colorful with everything so I'm always
highlighting things and crossing out or
is this stuff cool thank you for the
question sooo mad uh I think the most
important thing at least for me and what
I encourage with my team is that you
have to to get the benefits you have to
feel it i'm fully we can comment on this
team I think you have to feel it so just
like right three things down or just
saying yeah I'm given for my mom and the
Sun and the internet you know you don't
get the benefits because you're not
actually you have to have the emotional
connection so if I'm saying I'm grateful
for my mom like actually just thinking
about why am i grateful for my mom and
spending 30 seconds thinking about it so
I feel it here that's where I get the
benefit as opposed to just writing
something down on a piece of paper right
so whether you're writing it down
whether you're saying it I feel like the
most important part of this for me and
I'd love to hear your thoughts Felipe is
that you actually emotionally are
connected to that so if you're saying
thank God yeah I thank God and I think
my car that you know whatever just yeah
actually feel it you feel good before it
right yes has to be real right even what
you were what you were pointing and I
agreed one hundred percent is be true to
yourself be real be authentic be
generally have the habit to talk to
reality I'm telling you dream big but a
fetal true gratitude feel a true up
right through things dream big but right
true things and cross out things you
really did today or yesterday or things
you've done but what even saying I agree
one hundred percent feeling feel he has
to be real if it's not real it's like a
bubble sooner or later it do boo it will
blow up and I love it so so now thinking
about it so our entrepreneurs here
you're building a business we have a
team you know we've already seen some of
them in the as you turned around the
camera how to now that you've realized
how important this is for you what you
know the most successful entrepreneurs I
know of they like to now bring these
things that are working for them to the
people around them whether it's your
friends your family your team how do you
bring this to your team so you have
another board you have the bell practice
is there something that you do like if
you bring on a new person who may not do
a daily practice of gratitude that
you've just hired to be your new web
developer or whatever position in your
company how do you what do you do for
your team to make it because it's had
such an impact on you so that they're
doing it consistently to have an impact
on them as well hmm I I that I believe
they only learn these values if they see
me putting them in practice if they see
me doing and living what I say they'll
maybe start doing it they maybe they'll
consider doing it but like something I
value a lot of spirituality and by the
way last time we talked I arrived three
minutes late and I was no can't be like
aunt be late and I value a lot
punctuality so when they come for
interviews the last last interview of
our selection process here of our
recruiting
here is talking to me having an
interview with me and when everyone
arrives earlier for the job interview
everyone arrives early and when they are
hired maybe they get lazy about arriving
early erratic rhyming at the right time
and I always tell them I value
punctuality a lot but I tell them this
they only respect what I say after they
arrived here and i'm already in office
when they leave and i'm already and i'm
still here when I tell them 830 we study
together every Tuesday we get together
and we study together if I am late to
our meetings if I finish our lead our
meetings late they don't have the
example dude and if you don't show
people by giving the example it will be
hard to pass your values through them I
don't be correct be honest but if I
don't pay them on day one every month
with every cent they deserve do say hey
can you tell us to be correct you tell
us to be the best example but if you if
I'm not if I I'm not saying I'm perfect
I'm very far from being perfect but I
tried my best to be the best example to
everyone who works here with us I love
it and if your honor me and it's hard
when it's long distance relationship
even before the ones who were close to
me here in Brazil couple Minaj it's easy
but we have office in Mexico your start
in China when there is a distance it
becomes harder to show your examples and
to to demonstrate by action but anyway
you have to
show will have to do pyrex I love it um
one of the things that we did before i
started the morning gratitude stream was
i started a private facebook group for
myself and the key people on the team
and we would share every day three
things and i was in there to leading by
example sharing through things for me
I'm seen it's important I got to show up
and do it too and they would share three
things too and it also brought them
closer together on a non-business way in
that you know I'm grateful down I got
through that operation they go man what
happened with your mom is she okay like
it brings people together to on a much
deeper level so so yeah I'm a big fan of
leading by example to their um getting
getting some good comments here people
are grateful that we arrange his webinar
so you've got some new fans from from
believe nation here um there was a
question about frequency so is writing
it down once a day enough should I be
doing it more what are your thoughts on
frequency of being grateful we're
showing that they're writing their
taking the action and you need to build
a habit to first be grateful and then to
treat to write things down and cross
what you've done what I mean by that is
i have my to-do list here i have to
transfer some money to my to my
company's account i have to buy a door
door holder I think this is the name in
english and i have to transfer the
document of a motorcycle i bought these
things i wrote in the morning two of
them I've already done so i have to
cross here the transfer all right then
the motorcycle daughter have already
done if I don't do
it until I don't do it I don't throw
this paper out this paper is very very
early but I won't put it into rubbish
until I finish what I'm supposed to do
this is my strategy to be efficient I'm
not I'm not efficient if I don't write
things down if I don't have a reminder
in my cell phone if I don't write things
there in my wife today during lunch time
she told me give me yesterday I almost
got a bit nervous with you because you
asked me the same thing four times
because I was asking her love what do we
have to do tonight love what do we have
to the tonight why because I didn't take
note of our night schedule so write
things down and go for now yeah i think
if yours if you want to start the habit
of a gratitude practice don't don't set
yourself up for failure don't say i'm
going to be grateful ten times a day you
know if you're starting from nothing
have it have it once a day like once a
day consistently is so much better than
nothing right yes it makes a huge
difference and as you get used to do it
once a day you'll find other
opportunities throughout the day to do
it as well uh whenever I'm trying to do
a new habit I try to put in the morning
because you're more likely to do it in
the morning then if it's at the end of
the day your day starts exploding on you
so and this is have to take long like
Philippe how long does it take you to do
your gratitude prayer in the morning ah
two minutes maybe right so do two
minutes five minutes it's not it's not
I'm not when I asked you to take 90
minutes out of your day to do this right
so two minutes in the morning put it on
your calendar whether you use a book or
a google calendar or your email whatever
put it in there so you can check it off
and 42 minutes just sit there and think
about things you're grateful for do that
once a day set yourself up for success
if that starts working for you then you
can do it more often but I think too
often with new habits even like I want
to learn a new language I'm going to go
check out your service
learn a new language it's an to commit 5
our city to do it they're going to fall
off pretty quickly if I can do it in
small chunks daily are much more likely
to the stick to the Hat remember for
sure yeah cool well it's crazy how
quickly a time flies sleeping we're
having fun we're getting lots of good
comrades people more people from Brazil
Erica Pia Nora hope I pronounced that
okay watching in and people around the
world for people who've been inspired by
this felipe they want to learn more
about you what you're all about your
message where is the best way to to
reach you guys gone post a free job or
calm or to open in desoto calm or use
feet naw Kham or send me a message on my
facebook more heavily on a me on
snapchat gb philly be my snapchat is div
fel I'll de GD Philly be perfect i think
we linked up the websites in the
description below to so check that out
all right Felipe man thank you so much
for sharing some gratitude for giving us
some wisdom and inspiration thank you
guys all for watching live as well
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and we'll see you soon all right
thank you even thanks guys I'm finna pgp
see you next class much love it